what is more important in the history of
the development of human civilization
sex or violence
so mating strategies or military
strategies
oh well both are important i mean uh
first of all
humans are sexually reproducing species
and so everything has to go through sex
you know so in
our mating psychology has to be very
rich and complex
because uh to succeed
for us to be here now
all of our ancestors in a an unbroken
chain
have had to succeed in selecting a
fertile mate attracting that mate
be mutually chosen by that mate
stay together long enough do all the
sexual things you need to do to
reproduce have the kids survive etc so
everything has to go through mating and
in that sense i think it's uh i mean
survival is really only uh a means to an
end if you if you will uh so uh so so
sex has got to be important and humans
have a very rich
evolved sexual psychology or and
involves mating psychology okay but
uh i wouldn't minimize the importance of
violence either
there's a ton of evidence that humans
evolved in the context of small groups
and with a fair amount of small group
warfare
so intertribal
uh where uh
and this is a harsh realization but
there historically um this is part of
our bad evolutionary history it has been
advantageous from a purely reproductive
standpoint
to
conquer
a neighboring group kill the males
and
get whatever resources they have
including
females and and sexual resources to as
well as tools weapons
territory and so forth and so
um and so i think that we have
of course it's it's typically males
um who do that i mean yes some females
have participated in warfare but uh as
far as i know there's never been a
single case in all of human recorded
history of women forming a war tribe
with other women to attack another group
of women and kill them and capture the
men
as husbands but the these uh this
phenomenon is common um in the
ethnographic record
and small group uh studies
um it's part of our common thing so just
one concrete example unfortunately he's
dead now he passed away napoleon chagnon
he studied the yanga mamo for many many
years
um when he first started interviewing
them he he asked them
you know why do you go to war um and
they said well
to to capture women of course but it's
the only sensible
reason and they said you know why do why
does your culture go to war or however
they phrased it and he said well you
know we could were for to spread
democracy and ideas and everything they
basically fell off their logs laughing
at such a stupid reason because why risk
your life for anything
um other than women of course it's more
complex than that because some
go to war for
reputational reasons they say if we if
we don't
retaliate because we've been attacked
and they've stolen three of our women if
we don't retaliate then we will get a
reputation as exploitable and then other
groups will start to attack us as well
and so they get into these cycles of um
you know like the hatfields and mccoys
of attacks counterattacks retribution
and part of it is is um reputation
management
um so that's that's between groups and
and i think that's been the the primary
source of
violence but not the only source so
there's also within group conflict and
so many
ethnographies many traditional societies
have
things some of them are ritualized like
wrestling matches or uh in diana mama
they have uh these uh we're used to
these uh chest pounding duels where so
if we're in this match you challenge me
and i have to of course chest pounding
duel
like this yeah yeah so it's not you're
not hitting each other you're just it's
like peacocking you oh no you're hitting
each other oh sorry so they they get 20
paces away and they they
run up and
you punch the other guy in the chest and
he has to basically stand there
and then he does the same and everything
oh wow uh and then it's basically last
man standing that's well i suppose
that's better than the face
that's an interesting decision with the
chest yeah i mean i'm sure if you get
good at that kind of thing you could
start breaking ribs yeah and you can get
loose about the rules of where exactly
in the chest you can hit whatever
and there's that guy who's always known
for hitting not exactly in the chat
right where's it only missing right
right the the mike tyson of
eating your ear off
so interesting so there's like
ritualized uh conflict sort of uh
you purify the
uh the competition
that that that resolves some kind of
issue well yeah it's important to
establish status hierarchies you know um
but um
but also and here's here's just another
one more concrete point on on that the
yanama we don't have this in our
language we just have one word for
kill or murder but mama have um you're
either an una if you're a male you're an
unokai
or a non-unokai
the non unokai are men who have not
killed
if you're an unokai that means you have
killed someone and the unokai
among the anamamo historically had
higher status and more wives said
they're a a poliginous
uh society which is which has been true
of um something like 83 to 85 percent of
uh traditional societies